Selam bugün bir soruyla başlamak
istiyorum Herhangi bir alanda zirvede
olan insanları düşünün sanatta boyda
bilimde ya da başka bir alanda Sizce bu
insanların zirveye ulaşmasında hangisi
daha etkilidir gelme Emek mi geldi
yerleri görebilir miyim hiçbir şey
görmüyorum Gerçi
bu emek diyenleri görebilir miyim ha bu
alkış daha iyi fikir Evet teşekkür
ederim Şimdi Tabii ki sadece iki faktör
etkili değil tabii ki bir çok faktörün
etkileşimi söz konusu ama çok sık
sorulan sorular var kazanmak ve
kaybetmek Bunlar biyolojik Piyango larla
mı daha ilgilidir yoksa tutkulu bir
çabayla mı yetenekli doğulur mu yoksa
sonradan geliştirilebilir mi Ben bugün
bunları iki sporcunun hikayesi üzerinden
anlatmak istiyorum ilkinin Adı Stephen
Home defa İsveçli bir yüksek atlamacı
çok küçük yaşlardan itibaren yüksek
atlamacı olmayı kafasına koyuyor bunda
bir sebebi var o dönemde olimpiyat
şampiyonu İsveçli bir yüksek atlamacı
var ve bütün çocuklar ona aşık yani
nasıl Biz çocukken cümleten Erol Evgin
âşıklık o dönemde de
bu işte benzer bir durum söz konusu ve
fan da Bu çocuklardan tanesi sürekli
komşunun oğlu ile birlikte yastıkları
üst üste dizip üstünden atlıyorlar falan
Babası da çok memnun bu durumdan Çünkü o
da zamanında sporcu olmak istemiş fakat
hayatın gerçekleri hayallerini
gerçekleştirmesine izin vermemiş O
yüzden istiyor ki oğlu hayallerine
kavuşsun ve stefana tam destek veriyor
şu fakat ufak bir pürüz var defanın Boyu
ufak yüksek atlama Malum bu gerektiren
bir şey herkeste dalga geçiyor olmayacak
duaya amin diyor bu çocuk diyorlar O
umursamıyor bunları yılı boyunca sebatla
azimle disiplinle çalışa çalışa çalışa
en sonunda 2004 Atina Olimpiyatları'nın
finali ne kadar geliyor ve ki şimdi yine
soruyorum 2004a
o Olimpiyatları'nın finalinde hangisi
kazanıyor genler ve genetik gerçekler mi
yoksa tutkulu çaba mı genler diğerleri
ağlayabilirmiyim Çünkü göremiyorum
ve tutkulu çaba kazanacak yerlerin
[Müzik]
izleyelim Evet defa o 2004
Olimpiyatları'nda altın madalyayı
kazanıyor ve bununla da yetinmiyor dünya
rekoru kırıyor tabi herkes şok içinde
Çünkü hiç kimse böyle bir sonuç
beklemiyor bunun üzerine İsveçli bilim
insanları hemen defa mı inceleme altına
alıyorlar Vine görüyorlar Işıl topu Asil
topu sürekli olarak çalışmaktan Normal
bir insanın ki ne göre tam 4 kat daha
kalınlaşmış ve
en yüksek atlamada müthiş bir avantaj
adet abi kanguru kası gibi diğer tarafa
suya bilmesini sağlıyor bir çok büyük
bir ilgi var televizyonlardan
röportajlar gazetelerden röportajlar ve
herkes aynı soruyu soruyor başarının
sırrı nedir telefonun cevabı çok net
başarımın Sırrı yok diyor burada bir
mucize yok hatta Elinde mal kumlar verin
out Live kitabı var ki benim gibi
yıllarca 10000 saat Belki daha fazla
sebatla disiplinle çalışan herkeste bu
başarıyı yakalar da peki Ne bu 10.000
saat kuralını belki duy anlarınız vardır
bu arkasında Aslında Bilimsel bir
araştırma var Profesör an ders Ericsson
khloe Doğu Üniversitesi'nden bir
profesör şu sorunun cevabını merak
ediyor herhangi bir alanda 12 alan
istisna olabilir
bu olağanüstü performansı ulaşan kişiler
dahi diye gördüğünüz kişiler veya işte
müthiş başarılar yakalayan kişiler
seviyeye ulaşana kadar ne kadar
çalışmışlar araştırmanın çok ayrıntısına
Girmeyeceğim ama şunu buluyor Kemal
öğrencileriyle yaptığı bir araştırma ile
başlayarak ilk önce yaklaşık olarak bu
insanlar 10000 saat boyunca çalışmışlar
20 yaşına gelene kadar Hatta bunu
örnekler veriyor Ericsson mesela muzlar
hepimiz mozart'ı Çocuk dahi olarak
biliriz fakat Mozart altı yaşına gelene
kadar 1500 saat pratik yapmıştır babası
müzik öğretmenidir ve onu çalıştırmıştır
veya Tiger Woods Tiger Woods on beş
yaşında Amerika'nın en genç gol
şampiyonu olmuştur Fakat kaç yaşında
başlamıştır golf ve daha dokuz aylıkken
daha bezi atmamış cannn
bu eline golf sopası almıştır Tiger
Woods veya İdil Biret dört yaşında bahçe
almaktadır olağanüstü bir yetenektir
fakat annesi Piyanist ir evlerinde
piyano vardı herkes senden başlamıştır
eğitimi O yüzden evi.son diyor ki
Herhangi bir alanda dahi olağanüstü diye
gördüğünüz insanların Aslında geri
planına baktığınızda çok çok yoğun bir
çalışma süreci vardır Peki o zaman şunu
sorabilirsiniz Ben de 10 yıldır kendi
işimdeyim niye hala zirvede değilim
ericksoncu ki Belki bir şey yanlış
yapıyorsun ne şekilde çalıştığını önemli
bir içli pratik diye bir kavramdan söz
ediyor Bir içli pratik Çok etkili bir
eğitim tekniği hepimizde kendi alanımız
Her neyse bunu uygulayabilir Ve
inanılmaz bir ilerleme kaydedebiliriz
bunu belli adımları var
111 hedef belirleme ve iki bu Hedef
doğrultusunda tercihen bir uzmanla
birebir çalışma 3 sık sık tekrar etme 4
yoğun bir biçimde odaklanma 5
kapasitesini her seferinde birazcık daha
zorlama altı kendini samimi bir biçimde
eleştirme gerçekçi olmak ve 7 hataların
için anında geri bildirim alma
bu Peki o zaman aklı bir sonraki soru
geliyor diyelim ki genetik avantajlı bir
var bu kadar da çalışmadı karşısında da
10000 saat çalışmış çok güzel disiplini
bir biçimde bilinçli pratik yapmış
birisi var ikisi karşı karşıya gelirse o
zaman ne olur için bir sonraki hikayeme
geçeceğim dağıttığımız bahamalı bir
basketbolcu O da basketbol amık iş bir
tutkuyla bağlı bir gün üniversitede
kantinde arkadaşlarıyla oturuyorlar işte
iddiaya giriyorlar dağıtıyor ki ben şu
kadar yükseğe sıçra Biliyorum sana
çatarken arkadaşlarına gel göster o
zaman diyorlar hemen okulun yakınındaki
tek atlama sahalarına gidiyorlar ve
Donald daha ilk akla masında Ayağında
basketbol ayakkabıları var yani yüksek
atlama ya uygun bir ayakkabı bile yok
daha ilk akla masında neredeyse R
korkuyor arkadaşları çok içindeler Hemen
onu alıp okulun koçu
ne diyorlar hoş bakıyor karşısında
müthiş bir cevher var Hemen en yakın
yarışmaları hazırlamaya başlıyor onu ve
ilk girdiği yarışmada dünya dördüncüsü
oluyor Bir sonraki büyük yarış 2007
dünya oyunları Japonya'da bunu
hazırlanması için aşağı yukarı
başlangıçtan itibaren bir yıl kadar
süresi var fakat da noktada şöyle bir
durum var Evet genetik avantajı var boyu
çok uzun ama onun da Tutkusu yok Tutkusu
boyundan çok çok daha küçük iki pratik
yapıyorsa üçüncüde basket sahasına
gidiyor çünkü basketbolun gönlünde yatan
Aslan böyle böyle bir şekilde 2007/7
rapone Ya Dünya oyunlarının finaline
kadar geliyor finalde karşısında kim var
ilk defa nhay bir tarafta 20 yıldır
bilinç yapan tutkuyla yüksek atlama ya
bağlı ancak boyu kısa defa var Öbür
tarafta Neyse bir yıldır ratik yapan
içinde basketbol aşkı olan yüksek atlama
ile pek de işi olmayan ama inanılmaz
genetik avantajı olan bir danıp tamışvar
bizce Yetenek neydi Cehennemi Emek mi
geldi yerleri duyabilir miyim
bu emekli yerleri duyabilir miyim peki
izleyelim bakalım üzmelisin atlarsa o
kızın maalesef film sevgi emektir Selvi
boyludan uzun kazanıyor Samet ona baba
diyor
ilk defa ne yapıyor Sefa ne yapıyor
meslek değiştiriyor ne mesleği meslekte
istiyorum hocam Öyle mesleği iplik
kumarbazlık ve ahlaksızlık massive
Evet şimdi Ne diyordum şöyle bir durum
var tabii ki böyle bir şey olmuyor Sefa
mesleğe devam ediyor ancak tanıkla
ilgili durum şu başarısının ardından bir
santimetre bile daha yükseğe atlayamıyor
ve yıllar içerisinde performansı giderek
daha da azalıyor Ama tabi benim gönlüm
sefadan yana diye darıldın hikayesini
önemsiz gösterecek değilim çünkü her
ikisinden de öğreneceğimiz çok şey
olduğuna inanıyorum birincisi şu
yeteneğin keşfini hesabı üfle bırakmak
zorunda değiliz olduğu gibi eğer erken
dönemde çocukların neye yatkınlığı
olduğunu anlarsak ve onun üzerinden
onları desteklerse eğitim değilsek o
zaman olmaz sonuçlar olabilir Bir
çabayla gene böyle Tellioğulları
Seferoğulları gibi karşı karşı koymak
zorunda değiliz zürafayı Ergenin üzerine
eklerse
he he sonuçlar var Ancak bunda Tabii 4
kanın kesişimini önemli buluyorum kalp
karakter kabiliyet ve kariyer kart şu
kalbin için çarpıyor sabah seni
uyandıran Ne Eğer bunu bulabilmiş sen
çok şanslısın karakterinin güçlü yanları
neler ve zayıf yanları neler kendini
Tanıyor musun bu anlamda tabiyet neye
doğal olarak yatkınlığı var Eğer buna
göre bir kariyer tasarımı yaparsan o
zaman gerçekten Hem anlamlı hem tatmin
edici hem başarılı bir hayat seni
bekliyor olabilir ve gördüğünüz gibi
başarıya giden yol tek değil kimin
Tutkusu boyundan büyük Kiminin boyu
tutkusundan büyük hepimizin farklı
alanlarda avantajları var o yüzden
sormamız gereken soru şu benim yolum
Hangisi ben bana verilenlerin üzerine ne
ekleyebilirim
bu ve tabi dediğim gibi Benim gördüm
Ondan yana Çünkü bana göre olimpiyat
ruhunu o temsil ediyor insanın
olağanüstü kapasitesini o temsil ediyor
Aşil topu mitolojide insanın en zayıf
yönü simgeler o en zayıf yönünü alıp
çalışarak Sebat ederek en güçlü yönüne
şampiyonlar çeviriyor nietzsche'nin bu
sözünü çok seviyorum mükemmel olanı
nasıl olduğunu sorgulamalıyız birşeye
Tanrı vergisi demek onunla yarışmaya
gerek yok demektir diyor ve belki de
böylesi işimize geliyor Çünkü kim 10000
saat boyunca oturup bilinçli pratik
yapacak çalışacak genetikse o kadar
güzel diziler varken Ama neye odaklanır
Sak onu büyütürüz günde 3 saat boyunca
sosyal medyada gezi ne biliriz do3 saati
hayalimizi gerçekleştirmeye de odaklı ya
biliriz ve eğer
Eğer bunu yaparsak kendimizin bile
inanmayacağı bir değişim ortaya
çıkabilir ve her şeyden önemlisi
potansiyelimiz de saklı olanı ortaya
koyabiliriz o tavsiye elini
gerçekleştiremeyen organizma zamanla
hasta olur diyor yılım Jack belki
Stephen gibi dünya şampiyonu olmayız
belki oluruz bilmiyoruz ama kendi en iyi
versiyonu muzu Ulaşırız ki bu biri
yeterince güzel Herşeyden öteye
gösterdiğimiz bu çaba bu Sebat bu
disiplini çalışma o düşmeler kalkmalar
karakteri inşa eder ve karakter çok
önemli yetenek sizi zirveye taşıyabilir
ama orada kalmanızı sağlayan
karakterinizdir diyor Zonguldak'ın şu
anda en çok ihtiyaç duyduğumuz şey
karakterli zeka karakterli yetenek değil
Bence öyle ailene ve eğer
o dönemde Eğer sahne ışıkları bu
yeteneğin zekânın üstünün üzerinde
olursa o zaman daha önemli olan Sebat
gibi Azim gibi çaba gibi karakter
becerileri gölgede kalıyor ve onun da
muhteşem olduğu söylenen o çocuklar bu
muhteşem liflerinin çalışmak
gerektirmediğini düşünerek 20 yerine
geldiğinde ve sakla yaşıyorlar O yüzden
her zaman söylediğim birşeydi kez daha
tekrar etmek istiyorum Lütfen çocuklara
yaklaşırken zekalarını değil çabalarını
örelim yeteneklerini değil çabalarını
örelim ve son olarak burada Mehmet okula
bir hatıra fotoğrafın var görüyorsunuz
insan
en yeni Türk gerçeklerini kabul
etmeyelim bir yılını düz buradan
geçirerek düz olmasını sağlayamazsın
diyor bir Japon atasözü kendini
tanıyacaksın Mehmet okula Biz bir tedex
etkinliğinde karşılaşmış söyle bir cümle
kurdu Ben doğduğumda 63 santimetre yedim
dedim ben şu anda Rezalet ancak yani
böyle birşey ulaşmıştı emdiğini
zorlamayı düşünmüyorum Mehmet Okur'un
anlatmamın bir sebebi var onun
hikayesini çok anlamlı buluyorum okulda
başarısız bir öğrenci tembel olduğu
düşünülüyor haftası çalışmıyor diyorlar
ve ailesi çaresiz onu okuldan alıyor ve
basketbola veriyorlar var doğal
yatkınlık alanı buluyor Ve onun üzerine
çabayı da ekledim mi Bir Efsane doğruyu
Çünkü ait olduğu yer buluyor Ve belki
mesele hayatta ait olduğumuz yer
bulabilmek Einstein çok ün
ne var aslında herkes dahidir ama bir
balığı ağaca tırmanma yeteneğine göre
değerlendirirseniz bütün hayatını a****
olduğuna inanarak geçiriyor ve evler
yüzebildiğini bilmeyen balıklarla dolu
okullar sınıflar yüzebildiğini bilmeyen
kendini tembel sana a**** sanan
yeteneksiz sanan işe yaramadığını
düşünen çocuklarla Doğru O yüzden son
mesajım şu Lütfen çocukların
yapamadıkları şeyleri üzerinden onları
etiketleyip hayata küstürmek yerine
yapabildikleri şeyleri odaklanıp
kendilerini gerçekleştirmelerine destek
verelim Çünkü her çocuk Her insan Buna
mı Kader teşekkür ederiz